[Música]
muchos de vosotros habéis pasado cientos
de veces delante de una cárcel
de verdad creéis saber cómo es estáis
seguros
o tan sólo tenemos una idea hecha a
través de películas de series de
documentales que no se acercan a lo que
es la esencia de la realidad
porque no son las rejas
no son los muros ni siquiera las celdas
aunque fuera una jaula de oro con
piscina olímpica nada cambiaría
porque el infierno
son los otros
y el hecho que le di día tras día no hay
lugar donde esconderse el infierno es
que ni las leyes ni las reglas y las
normas pueden defendernos porque no se
pueden cumplir
en la baja edad media se acuñó una frase
para explicar el conflicto entre la
realidad y la autoridad
obedezcas
pero no se cumpla
esto qué quiere decir
que la ley está por encima de todo
pero que no se puede ejecutar
en el mundo de las prisiones
establece una lucha fraticida entre
seguridad y libertad
pero siempre que gana una
es a costa de la otra
es un simple dilema que jamás se ha
resuelto en el vaivén del péndulo de la
historia
os lo voy a explicar siguiendo un camino
con diferentes etapas
hacia ninguna meta vamos a ver qué le
pasa a alguien
que ingresa por primera vez en prisión
acompañarme
días 0 o despersonalizando que aún se
puede más
estamos en comisaría se detiene
degüellan le quitan todas sus
pertenencias le cachean integralmente le
retiran el cinturón y los cordones
alguien alguna vez se quitó la vida ya
no lo vais a pagar todos
le dejan hacer una llamada y le hacen
una foto y tras 48 horas sin ducharse y
comiendo bocadillos aceitosos el juez
decide que ingrese dentro del sistema
díaz 0 bis o todo se repite
estamos en el departamento de ingresos
le huella la quitan todas sus
pertenencias
leica sean integralmente
ya se ha vuelto un experto en el arte de
desvestirse
caballero primero en los zapatos
luego el pantalón
más tarde el resto
por último los calcetines y los casos y
ellos
haga usted una flexión
abra bien la boca
y no puede quedar ningún lugar por
escudriñar aún así hay quien consigue a
través de huecos y cavidades
entrar lo que sea como sea son las mulas
los increíbles hombres y mujeres cucha
que tragan dilatan o regurgitan con gran
facilidad sus codiciados tesoros
después le hacen la foto de rigor y el
funcionario de diseño
caballero tiene que llamar en estos diez
minutos si no puede conseguirlo cuando
vaya al módulo haga una instancia y
cuando venga aprobada podrá llamar
pero señor funcionario si no localiza a
nadie como me van a poner dinero para
que llame por teléfono mire no tenemos
tiempo y él ha visto el equipo de
tratamiento y el médico coja usted sus
cosas
el lote higiénico y las sábanas nos
tenemos que ir para el módulo
allí podré llamarlo
claro claro todo a su tiempo tenga usted
paciencia
en nuestro interno ha ingresado en un
entorno de incertidumbre en el que no
sólo se ha tenido que desahogar
sino que se siente desnudo y que la
frase que más veces ha oído durante todo
el día
haga usted una instancia
ya está loco por encontrar un bolígrafo
día 1 o tranquilo amigo tú no te
preocupes
la llegada al módulo
nuestro primaveras
va acompañado por el funcionario hasta
el módulo y le dice esperen te cancelas
llega el jefe de unidad viene con una
tablilla
mira los huecos
está todo masificado en cada celda solo
viven dos personas y solo hay un hueco
es la celda 24
pero va a vivir con barbosa es un
interno veterano que le va a explicar
cómo funciona todo y le enseñará a
rellenar distancias
barbosa se acerca y le diste
tranquila amigo
no te preocupes
si necesitas algo pídemelo
así que tienes familia y te pueden
asistir
qué suerte tienes bajo
relájate tú no te preocupes toma un
paquete de tabaco ya me lo darás cuando
te pongan dinero y relájate
me conocen me respetan nadie te va a
tocar y no te fíes de nadie aquí hay
mucho abuso van a querer que tú seas su
machacan porque lo que quieren de ti es
tu dinero es tu ropa
y tu culo para meter nuevas yo soy anti
abuso y anti drogas colegas
pasa el fin de semana
lo siento barbosa no han venido a verme
ni ha podido llamar cuando consiga
llamarles les diré que me manden un
ingreso por transferencia y te pagaré
pasada semana
amigo
yo no financió a nadie ahora me debes
mucho más y con intereses aquí las
deudas se pagan y si no se cobran
no soy ninguna hermanita de la caridad
además vamos a arreglarlo de esta manera
mira le vas a dar este número de cuenta
a tus papis
y cuando me lo ingresen nuestras celdas
nuestra cuenta estará saldada
pero además por los intereses me vas a
hacer un favor el próximo vis a vis que
hagas con tu mujercita un amigo mío le
va a dar un paquete cuando estés con
ella te vas al lavabo y te lo empiezas
ya puedes ir practicando
pero hacerla
y así es como nuestro
compañeros internos hombre ingresa en el
camino de la deuda
en el camino de la vergüenza y no se lo
digas a nadie ni a los funcionarios
porque porque nadie te dijo que te
empeñas es y además si se enteran te van
a llamar perra chivata
y los chivatos lo pasan muy mal en la
cárcel
además su compañero sabe dónde viven sus
padres por las cartas y le puede
extorsionar le ha pedido al jefe que le
cambio de celda pero no hay huecos solo
tiene una solución
enfrentarse
pero ayer cuando estaba en el tigre que
es como llaman al lavabo allí
vinieron amigos de él y le enseñaron un
pincho
allí no hay cámaras si los denuncia y
los cachean y lo encuentran sabrán que
ha sido él
y ya puede correr
otro interno elige si te dejas pensar
una vez que pisará siempre mira lo que
le pasó a joseph joseph entró con mono y
sin nada el jefe de los moros le dio
de todo luego le cortó el suministro
y por la abstinencia empezó a alucinar
se pasaba el día rezando adiós
a todas horas
y
estaba tan desesperado que por un
cigarrillo se pegó con otro compañero y
acabó en el especial cuando salió se fue
a vivir con uno que decían que estaba en
la yihad
todo mentira
se le ve con ropa de marca de coches
caros yo conozco a sus jefes
religiones importa la
se trata de armas dinero drogas mujeres
propiedades blanqueo ellos dicen esto no
hay mejor soldado
que un pecador arrepentido
y ahora lo sabes depender o no depender
esa es la cuestión
el dependiente busca será a otro
dependiente
el toxicómano a otro toxicómano el
fanático a otro fanático
y el esclavo
a otro esclavo
todos buscan elevarse en el círculo del
infierno que son los otros
así que tendrás que pelear o si no te ve
otorgando que hasta las cejas para
aguantar toda esta
y te lo dice alguien que no está
orgulloso
de haber chupado tanto talego
y así una persona que ingresa en prisión
en espera de juicio imaginaos que es
inocente
empieza un camino que le hará salir
culpable
día 199
ha pasado tiempo
o para que llore mi madre
que llore la tuya
al enfrentarse a la violencia nuestro
interno el o a otro módulo más
conflictivo porque igual que las deudas
también toda agresión se paga aquí hay
droga por todas partes los funcionarios
son pocos y además la normativa para los
registros es muy estricta y siempre
acompañado por un mando para que no nos
puedan acusar de trato vejatorio
trabajan con inseguridad con miedo
además la mayor parte de las denuncias
son de otros internos
por venganza por obtener ventajas
eliminar competencia
o cualquier otro motivo
para ellos la droga le quita un día juez
pero se la quitan a ellos mismos porque
la droga es
lo que lo tapa todo tapa lo que has
hecho
tapar a tus hijos tapa tu mujer tapa tus
padres
papá a toda tu familia a todos tus seres
queridos es el genérico para no pensar
para no sufrir
para no mirarse en el espejo y allí por
encima de todos manda el arruinado
pero tienes el arruinado
es un ser que tiene una condena tan
larga que piensa que no va a salir con
vida
todos le tienen miedo
porque carece de esperanza
sabes perfectamente que cumplirá su
palabra si te dice
su muerte me sale gratis
para que llore mi madre
que yo de la tuya
o sea que ya lo sabes
aquí pasamos a la fase 3 o el acto tres
día
1521 o es el camino de la libertad
antes acabamos unas preguntas
por ejemplo porque entra la droga como
entra la droga o sólo hay tres caminos
permisos vis a vis
y
se puede evitar que entren con los
medios que tenemos y sin atentar a los
derechos de las personas no se puede se
puede evitar la fanatización no se puede
se puede evitar
los abusos en prisiones
no se puede con los medios que tenemos
acto 3 día 1521 o es el camino de la
libertad es la hora de la libertad
se ha adaptado aquí para obtener
permisos ha hecho un programa de
rehabilitación
pero ahí está el problema
lo he hecho por la recompensa
lo ha hecho porque piensa que ha
cumplido su tiempo de estar allí y ahora
tiene derecho a salir pero en el fondo
no ha cambiado
oh sí sí que ha cambiado
ahora no es autónomo y los códigos de la
cárcel se le han incrustado en su ser
sin querer como una segunda piel
además
cuando sale del permiso tiene agorafobia
las distancias son demasiado largas y
anchas para alguien que se acostumbrado
a mirar hasta un muro además ha perdido
visión
y así lo podemos explicar como metáfora
de su propia vida
ahora ya no tiene miedo a la cárcel
ahora tiene miedo la calle
a la vida
a su nueva realidad
la cárcel va con él se le ha pegado
no sabe cómo saber
y ahora aparece el rostro del verdadero
enemigo y este se llama anomia
volvemos al inicio nos vemos atrapados
en el obedezca sé pero no se cumplan
las leyes proliferan multiplican se
contraponen
se interpretan
y la pereza mental nos domina al no
tener las cosas claras convivimos en una
institución esquizofrénica que intenta
conciliar la rehabilitación con la
vigilancia
pero para hacer esto posible genera un
mundo de leyes que por falta de medios
jamás se van a cumplir entonces qué
ocurre señores que nos limitamos a ser
simples dosificadores de la violencia de
depredadores contra depredados y cuando
ésta ocurre llegamos tarde y mal
para recoger y limpiar los restos del
desastre
además la pluralidad de normas que se
contradicen y anulan mutuamente hacen
que corremos el riesgo de pensar que
cualquier pauta de conducta pueda
parecernos válida
todo vale hecha la ley hecha la trampa
si ellos lo hacen porque yo no
y dejamos de preocuparnos y pensamos que
lo que ocurre es normal así de simple es
la banalidad del mal
y entonces vemos el rostro del enemigo
que es la anomia
la novia no es más que la desidia de
aceptar lo inaceptable es quien crea los
abu ghraib y los guantánamo de este
mundo es quien crea los campos de
concentración las cárceles secretas o
las junglas donde mandan las mafias por
eso hemos de luchar en la sociedad
porque señores la cárcel no es más que
su reflejo debemos de ir más allá pero
mucho más allá del esquema de vigilar y
castigar luchar por no conseguir que se
conviertan en contenedores donde arrojar
la basura
y luego olvidarnos
un amigo mío
un profeta de terrassa
me dijo
cuando leía john donne
escribió esto
nadie es una isla
o
la pregunta es por quién doblan las
campanas están doblando por ti entendí
una sencilla verdad
que la salvación de única de una única
alma
justificó la fundación del purgatorio
[Aplausos]